our nation was founded on the
fundamental principle that all people
should have the freedom to live to
worship and to be without fear of
violence or persecution every person has
the right to live safe from violence
hate and bigotry and for those reasons
and so many more President Joe Biden and
I have a duty not only to keep the
people of our nation safe but to condemn
unequivocally and forcefully all forms
of hate people can be as bigoted as they
want in fact as long as they're not
committing any crimes in the process
nobody has the right to be free from the
bigoted opinions and Views and attitudes
of other people that's the whole point
of the First Amendment it protects
speech that you think is good it also
protects speech that you think is bad
and as everyone says but few seem to
really believe when it comes down to it
the first amendment is really only ever
needed for that latter category